نجوم فيلم
قتلت زهره القمر الامريكيه المخرج معزي
خطفوا الانظار على السجاده الحمراء
بمهرجان كان السينمائي والذي يشهد العرض
الاول لهذا الفيلم النقاد والجمهور
استقبلوا هذا الفيلم الذي تبلغ مده عرضه
ثلاث ساعات و 26 دقيقه بحفاوه وبالغه وانا
لتصفيقا حارا من الحاضرين استمر تسع دقايق
الفيلم من بطوله
النجميو وهو ماخوذ عن روايه تحمل الاسم
نفسه اصدرت في عام 2017 وحققت مبيعات
قياسيه طبعا تدور احداثه عن سلسله من
جرائم القتل خلال عشرينيات القرن
الماضي في ولايه اوكلاهوما بعد اكتشاف
النفط يعدل استقبال الحار في المهرجان
اشاره جيده بالنسبه لشركه ابل اوريجينال
للافلام التي افادت بانها منحت سكورسيزي
ميزانيه قدرها 200
مليون دولار لتحويل الكتاب الى فيلم
سينمائي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات